well there aren't a lot of tv reporters
who actually break news stories anymore
so you notice when you find one and the
one we've noticed
a lot in the last year is bill malugen
you've seen him reporting for this show
from our fox station in la
today is his first day as a fox news
national correspondent we are thrilled
by this
bill on his very first day has an
exclusive new footage of an attack on a
police officer bill million
congratulations great to see you tonight
hey tucker thank you glad to be on the
team the video you're about to see here
it's really just a great a example of
the kind of animosity that some officers
out there are
encountering in the streets the video
it's actually not from department-issued
body cameras from
l.a county sheriff's department they're
still in the process of rolling all
those out
it comes from a deputy it's his own
personal body camera he's been on the
force
uh for 14 years and tells me he has his
own personal body camera
to kind of protect himself from from
false allegations when he's out there at
work and
it's a good thing he did that because
just a couple of weeks ago he did what
he thought was an average
traffic stop a woman was using her cell
phone while driving but
it quickly fell apart the woman went
after him started berating him making
racist comments
and anti-police comments take a look
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer yes i started to record because
you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving when i was recording you
because you said
you can't you can't use your cell phone
while you're recording you may i have
your driver's license
i it's it's at my apartment thank you
and i'm perfectly legal and i'm a
teacher
so there congratulations you're a
murderer
it's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go bam sign inside the river
for him being a mexican racist what is
that name
yes it's under citation man here you go
mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
not the nicest lady right there now fox
news has learned the name of this woman
but at this time we are not going to
identify her because we've reached out
to her multiple times
still have not gotten a comment from her
um i did talk to l.a county sheriff alex
villanueva about this he told me
he was appalled by what he saw in that
video there but he commended his deputy
for staying very professional
and just doing his job and remaining
calm take a listen
she claims to be a teacher and i
understand if it's southwest college
where she's teaching i'm not too sure
where but
if she represents her profession uh is
that an indictment on the pro
on her profession and the caliber of
people because you have one incident
like george floyd
and murder all right but some people
want to label the entire profession
as if everyone was a derek chalman and
this shows you that
bigotry racism comes in all colors in
all
ages and proof of that right there if
you want to call
all of the deputies murderers
unfortunately
you're doing the exact same thing which
you're accusing other people to do it
against your own pain
all right so here's the kicker here the
sheriff's department confirmed to me
today that the woman in that video
she actually called internal affairs and
filed a harassment complaint against
that deputy
right after that traffic stop happened
the department also tells me that that
woman
has a history of making false claims
against deputies so tucker
good idea for this deputy to have his
personal camera here might end up saving
them we'll send it back to you
glad she's teaching the kids bill
millusion thanks for that and welcome to
fox we're really glad you're here
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else